when the story broke the national
security advisor john bolton was fired
trump hating politico's and media types
seized on the departure as more evidence
that the doors are coming off the White
House the most convincing evidence that
we've seen of late that we have a
governing crisis the service had already
detected a significant amount of
disarray and chaos nobody last long in
the chaos of the Trump administration it
certainly projects instability to both
allies and adversaries alike I don't
think we can emphasize enough and I
heard from a senior Democratic foreign
policy made them if you will the amount
of dysfunction in the foreign policy
apparatus policy may even if you will
well as usual the lemmings are totally
jumping off the ledge together okay
here's what I learned when I was a 22
year old White House staffer you know
what I learned that you work at the
pleasure of the chief executive the
President of the United States so if you
accept any position in any
administration your job is to pursue the
goals of the president not your own your
job is to find ways to accomplish his
priorities not your own your job is to
advocate his worldview not your own
the president's entitled to the staff
that he wants and at any moment this is
a staff person who works directly for
the president United States and he
should have people he trusts and values
and whose efforts and judgments benefit
him and delivering American foreign
policy that was Pompeo today now I've
known John Bolton for decades he's
appeared on this show many times we
obviously really like him and respect
him very much but his position at the
White House let's all be honest it was
always going to be a complicated fit
now remember Bolton of course worked for
George W Bush and in one position as UN
Ambassador and in some areas he's closer
to the interventionist wing of the GOP
than he is to Trump's America first view
now I still remember when the Democrats
used to agree with being a less
interventionist power but then Trump
derangement syndrome took hold and
became walking contradictions of
themselves here's what Democrats sounded
like when Bolton was appointed John
Bolton didn't even know what he was
being hired for right let alone not
knowing that he was being hired and John
Bolton is a dangerous man John Bolton I
think is a disastrous pick when it comes
to John Bolton if Congress does not want
to go to war now is the time to start
putting restraints on this president
here's what they sound like now on a
couple key issues this failed idea for a
summit at Camp David and these colossal
failures with North Korea Bolton was
right you need a national security
adviser who's willing to give you
alternative views John Bolton will land
on his feet he also has acknowledged
about certain ways of the international
affairs international actions that could
be my favorite then and now ever by the
way
now even the liberal Nate Silver's saw
this for what it was in his tweet saying
maybe I'm a simpleton but it seems like
if you criticize Bolton's hiring you
probably shouldn't also criticize his
firing
well media goofballs are now focused on
the discrepancy on whether Bolton would
quit or whether it was fired he says the
former and released this terse
resignation letter dated today to prove
it
Trump said he asked for the resignation
translation fired him last night but who
cares which it was it was long overdue
Trump's allegiance isn't to any
particular process or to any particular
cabinet member but to the people who
elected him and to the country at large
he's a true maverick because he came
like a freight train at the old GOP
foreign policy establishment that had
gotten us bogged down in two costly wars
as China grew basically unchallenged
Trump promised to bring our troops home
from Afghanistan and yet the military
and national security officials have
mostly resisted him every step of the
way on that goal this frustrates the
president to no end
he knows that most Americans don't just
want our troops back home but they don't
even think the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan work with
but the old bush team of course they
won't take no for an answer
despite obama's election then Trump's
election of course Obama came in in 2008
then Trump in 2016 which represented a
bipartisan and total repudiation of the
Bush Doctrine we left our troops in
Europe for 45 years until Germany could
unify between 1945 and 1990 we're still
there we keep the peace on the Korean
Peninsula since 1953 and I know that
Americans are tired of some of the
responsibilities but frankly there's
nobody but the United States of America
that can do these well we love condi but
this isn't 1945 or 1953 it's the 21st
century and after two wars that began
post 9/11 this is where public opinion
is look at it 62% say Iraq wasn't worth
fighting 59% say Afghanistan wasn't
worth fighting so look contrary to being
a sign of chaos the Bolton news I think
shows a commitment to principle and
efficiency anyone who can't produce
results and anyone who can't get on
board with the President's agenda
shouldn't be inside working to oppose
him or undermine him HR McMaster was
canned after some thought he bumbled as
National Security Advisor Tillerson was
a colossal failure at the State
Department Pryce was fired a very nice
man at HHS after making no headway on
drug prices Kristin Nielsen was gone
when she couldn't manage the border
crisis sessions was shown the door at
DOJ after myriad mistakes including one
that led to the appointment of a special
counsel Gary Cohn quit when he lost the
debate on tariffs and let's not forget
Sierra Moochie he was out after ten days
as press secretary when it became too
much mooch and not enough Magga
president Trump is really impatient for
results and he's going to change
personnel as necessary to achieve them
I'll take that any day over someone who
cavalierly coasts on the status
quo or doubles down on failure with a
swagger Trump's foreign policy is best
described as prudent realism
he believes that given the fact that the
US economy now represents about twenty
to twenty five percent of the global GDP
we need to maximize our leverage wisely
Trump actually considers how much
military missions cost cost our
taxpayers of course their hard-earned
money and whether they make our life
here better and safer at home again the
bush is very patriotic people we honor
their service in government but they
didn't spend a lot of time worrying
about those details so looking back on
it is that approach more moral than
Trump's when our citizens here drive on
roads and bridges that are falling apart
most voters think we should fix our
schools in our airports before we try to
fix Syria's and right now
Trump has a stellar team in place just
to name a few Secretary of State Pompeo
attorney general bill Barr Bob light
hyzer at trade never been a trade rep
better than he steve nooshin at Treasury
Alex a czar at HHS phenomenal mark Esper
acting secretary of defense terrific
they all understand their role is to
advance the President's agenda that's
the way it works sure you offer your
advice and sometimes you debate
presidents fine with that but then you
get on board with whatever he decides
it's not your decision and if you cannot
do that then step aside for someone who
can everyone understand and that's the
angle